-Hayden, it is so good
to see you, bud.
-It's good to see you, too, man.
-First time on
"The Tonight Show."
-Yeah, with you, yeah.
-But we've known each other
for years.
-I know. We go back to
"The Factory Girl."
-We were in a movie together
called "Factory Girl"
with Sienna Miller.
-That's right.
-And you were fantastic.
We had fun.
-Likewise, yeah.
We had too much fun.
-We actually did, I think.
Yeah. [ Laughs ]
We actually probably had
too much fun, yeah.
Do you remember how impressed
you were by my acting?
You were like,
"Jimmy, you should
go into the talk show business."
[ Laughter ]
-I actually, I remember meeting
you for the first time,
and I was playing a character
that was
loosely based on Bob Dylan,
and the first time we met,
you went into, you know,
one of your impersonations
of Bob Dylan.
And I was so blown away by it.
I was like, "Oh, my goodness.
Why aren't you playing
this role?"
-No. Oh, my God, no.
You crushed it, come on, man.
I want to say congrats on the
success of "Obi-Wan Kenobi."
-Thanks.
-It is the biggest thing
in the world.
[ Applause ]
And couldn't happen to
a nicer dude.
-Thank you.
-The finale dropped
on Wednesday.
It was trending number one
on Twitter
for the next three days
after that.
But first, I want to go back
to talk about
when you first got cast
as Anakin Skywalker.
-Yeah.
-You were straight out of
high school, right?
-Yeah, I was in high school,
like, a year before,
doing school plays.
-Where were you?
Like, in Canada?
-Yeah, I was living in Vancouver
at the time.
It was a long audition process.
And I was renting an apartment
with a friend of mine,
and he knew I was
up for this role
and I was gonna be
finding out soon.
I got the call.
I was shocked, in disbelief.
I remember walking into
the living room,
just with this, like,
big smile on my face.
And he kind of
put the dots together,
but to confirm it for him,
you know,
I lit up an imaginary lightsaber
like --
[ Imitates lightsaber sound ]
-[ Laughing ] Yes!
-He got it.
-You're like --
-He was a big fan, too.
-That's great.
-He had the "Star Wars"
soundtrack,
and he put the
"Duel of the Fates" on
and we had a whole
lightsaber battle,
sort of jumping all around
our apartment.
Just screaming like
giddy little kids.
-Excited, that's what
it's all about.
That's so cool.
-It was amazing.
-All these years later now,
you're in the new
"Obi-Wan Kenobi."
You get to really full-on
Darth Vader.
We had Ewan McGregor
on the show
a couple weeks ago.
He said when he first saw you
as Darth Vader,
he was frightened.
Like, he actually was
actually scared
and he was like,
"I felt like, actually,
really frightened.
Everyone on set, too."
Do you feel that,
when you wear the costume
and you dress as Darth Vader?
-Yeah, I mean, you know,
it's an amazing costume
to get to put on.
It's an honor to get to wear it.
But definitely the best part
is just
seeing people's reaction,
you know, when they see Vader.
You have, like --
-Is it easy to see
out of those eye things?
-No, I mean, it's very
limited visibly,
but when someone does come
across your field of vision...
-They're frightened.
-You see sort of the change
in their demeanor, you know?
Like, people who are usually
very confident
become a little more timid
and shy.
It's good fun.
-I wanted to ask, because you're
the only person I can ask.
Does it get hot?
-It's so hot, yeah.
No, you're sweating buckets
in it the whole time.
-You are, right?
-Yeah, yeah.
But they actually have, like,
an under component to the suit
where, if you get too hot,
they plug you into this machine
and it pumps cooling liquid
all around your body
to sort of cool you down.
-Really?
-Yeah.
Which, again, sort of aids to
the whole feeling like
you're this mechanical creature
relying on this mechanism.
-Wow.
-To keep you going, yeah.
-That's good to know.
That's cool.
I know also, when we
first meet you,
you're very damaged and scarred,
Anakin.
-I am.
-Great prosthetics for that.
-Amazing prosthetics.
-How many hours for that?
-It was like, a good
four to five hours
every time we did it.
-And then you have to go act.
-Yeah.
I mean, you know,
it's an amazing visual creation
that takes place every time
they do it,
and it really helps you
sort of feel the character.
But then, end of the day,
when you have to take it off,
that's a different story.
-That scrubbing and pulling
and scrubbing, yeah.
So you're like, alright,
what do I like better,
that or this hot mask?
You're like, I don't know.
Yeah.
By the way, your beautiful
little daughter, 7?
Did she know that Daddy
is Darth Vader?
-She knows Daddy's Darth Vader.
She's never seen Daddy
as Darth Vader.
I'm still waiting a little bit,
you know,
until that happens.
-You could probably
show her the...
-I might show her the prequels
soon.
-Yeah.
-But still, there's some scenes
we might have to
fast forward through.
-That's true, yeah.
-But...
-Does she have a lightsaber?
-We have a couple lightsabers
kicking around the house,
and actually, she was my first
lightsaber training partner,
when I came back to
the "Obi-Wan" show.
-That's what I'm
talking about, buddy.
-Yeah.
-The series finale began
streaming Wednesday,
and I don't want to
give away any spoilers,
for anyone out there
who's watching the show
and not caught up.
It's very interesting,
doing a talk show
when you're not really allowed
to talk about anything.
[ Laughter ]
It happens a lot.
And then even when it's out,
like,
it's been out for,
things are out for years
and they go, "Don't mention
what's happening."
So just in case people
haven't --
But this is fresh,
as of Wednesday.
What can we say about
the finale?
[ Laughter ]
-Again, not a lot
without spoiling anything.
[ Laughter ]
-I knew that!
I knew that.
-But no, there's some
great stuff,
and there's a very
emotional confrontation
between Obi-Wan and Vader
that was a real sort of
privilege to get to film.
-With Ewan?
-With Ewan, yeah.
-He's a great guy.
He's a great actor.
-I love the man to bits, yeah.
-Yeah, it's good.
It does get very kind of
emotional.
Congrats again on everything,
buddy.
You know I love you, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Hayden Christensen
and Ewan McGregor
in "Obi-Wan Kenobi."
Take a look at this.
[ Whirring ]
-I do not fear the Dark Side!
I see through the lies
of the Jedi.
♪♪
-Help me, Master Qui-Gon.
Give me strength.
♪♪
[ Beeping ]
-Anakin Skywalker is alive.
♪♪
He's been looking for you
for a long time.
♪♪
[ Deep, labored breath ]
[ Applause ]
-Yes! Come on!
Hayden Christensen, everybody!
"Obi-Wan Kenobi" is streaming
now on Disney Plus.
Preacher Lawson is performing
stand-up after the break.
Stick around, everybody.